[Music]
good evening time then for the press
preview we're checking out monday's
front pages and joining me tonight to
look at the headlines the political
editors of the daily mirror and the sun
pepper carrera and harry cole they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight uh keeping cool at home a very
good evening to you too uh we'll chat in
a moment after we've looked at those
front pages starting with the guardian
which hears that we should know
who the next prime minister is by
september the 5th after the rules were
laid out today for the conservative
leadership contest the ft understands
that the former chancellor rishi sunak
will attempt to stave off criticism for
refusing to offer tax cuts if he becomes
prime minister by saying he'll do so
only once inflation is under control
in fact that's also the lead for the
times which says allies of boris johnson
are rallying behind liz truss the
foreign secretary meanwhile has
reportedly warned the right of her party
to back her or let rishi sunak into
number 10 that's in the daily mail now
according to the telegraph the
government is mulling plans for a first
of its kind national heat emergency in
the coming days
the metro reports that the former f1
boss bernie ecclestone is to be charged
with fraud after an investigation into
overseas assets believed to be worth
more than 400 million
pounds the sun praises athlete samo
farah for coming forward to admit that
he was smuggled here from somalia as a
child and that mo farah isn't his real
name quite remarkable that
it also makes the front page of the eye
which reports the home office has
dismissed claims he will be stripped of
british citizenship
and don't forget you can scan the qr
code you can see on screen during the
program check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you listen and
watch us discussing them and we're
joined tonight by people carrera and
harry cole lovely to see you both um
what a few days it has been and what a
few days it is going to be um let's
start with the guardian pippa the rules
are set the race is very much on uh sir
graham brady outlining how it's all
going to pan out a bit earlier this
evening 20 backers needed to get on the
ballot is that reasonable are the rules
sensible
they certainly are i mean this is the
broadest uh tory leadership
campaign uh for for a long time for many
many years there's 11 candidates thus
far and we may yet see more uh
as nominations close tomorrow yet see
more sticking the head above the parapet
um and obviously the big concern as far
as the 1922 committee is concerned that
back bench um executive of tory mps
is that they need to there's so many
pressures facing the country with cost
of living crisis and there's also a
conflict on going in ukraine that they
can't really afford to have a government
that is basically
in a sense paralyzed um the caretaker
government not actually able to take any
sort of substantial action to tackle
some of those those issues uh which is
of course what the boris johnson
government now is that caretaker
government so they want to crack on as
fast as possible to allow those
candidates to the successful candidate
to get into number 10
and of course there's still this sort of
question this cloud if you like about
boys johnson's integrity and there's a
lot of bunnies remaining on the back
benches about the fact that he despite
the fact he's resigned that he's likely
to be in number 10 for another couple of
months so the consensus is that they
want to crack on as fast as possible and
the best way to do that given the the
breadth of the fields is to is to
increase the threshold as they have done
not just on getting onto the ballot
paper in the first place
um that used to be eight and it's now
gone up to 20 mps a candidate would need
to back them but also getting through to
the next round and that's gone up to 30
and the plan is to sort of put this on
fast forward have a couple of votes this
week and hopefully the final vote should
decide the last two candidates and then
go to tori and peace touring members
across the country early next week so
what it means harry is that we know 11
people on the list so far many of them
may not even make the first stage
yeah i'm pretty sure many of them
shouldn't have really made this stage
but uh frankly given the caliber of some
of the people that have been expressing
interest in throwing their names forward
normally these things happen you know
some five or six
mps um
throw their names into the hat for um
felida it shows you just exactly what
the the prime minister the current just
about prime minister's allies was
warning late last week when it looked
like he was going south
um but this time last week when it
looked like he was going south is
actually what is what is what is your
alternative and it turns out the tory
party have stabbed the most electorally
successful prime minister they've had in
30 years and replaced it with frankly
what is looking like a fairly
embarrassing um circus
um and i think the the sort of wiser
hands of graham brady is less about what
pippa says about you know this unease
about boris johnson staying in in in
office that started to dissipate really
since the end of last week and actually
it's about lasting damage to the
conservative party's you know reputation
as a grown-up competent um party when
they can't even decide 12 of them uh you
know half the cabinet and half the
cabinet who were in the cabinet last
week but no longer in the cabinet
thinking that their colleagues are
frankly crap and not not not good enough
to their own
it looks really bad well i see why the
public elders have rushed forward to try
and get them to sort this out quickly
because it's frankly getting a bit
embarrassing well harry um
we know they want to speed the process
up we're still not going to get a new
prime minister a new conservative leader
till september the 5th i mean that gives
us loads of time doesn't it for the tory
party to to tear itself apart lots of
blue on blue bloodletting
absolutely i mean that's already started
frankly uh so far we've had dodgy
dossiers and you know nadine dorrie's
the ultra loyalists of boris johnson's
been out
um
already this tonight is accusing washi
sunakku being a part-timer who was
spending all his time plotting his
leadership campaign you know you've got
richie's tsunami coming out tomorrow i
think the embargo is just about lifted
so we can say this he's basically going
to call his rival candidates liars and
being dishonest with the public by
suggesting that they could have all
these wonderful tax cuts that he calls
fairy tales and that's only going to get
worse you've got you've got james
cleverley i think in the times tomorrow
from what i was reading just before we
came on there saying that actually rishi
sanak was a labour a labor uh chancellor
which is frankly you know so why is our
hands are saying be careful now because
the new leader isn't going to inherit a
government and an election winning
political party at this rate they're
going to inherit a bin fire um let's
have a look at we just showed you uh the
front the financial times we can have a
look again it's a similar theme soon act
to defend tax stance by vowing cuts once
inflation is tamed uh pippa he's pretty
much on his own isn't he when uh when it
comes to uh tax policy at the moment
he's the book his favorite though um
what's going to happen to those uh uh
more on the right are they going to have
to come together and sort out who is
best to stand up against him
i think almost certainly i mean this is
a big issue on the right i was talking
to lots of mps today that are concerned
that the right is being split by between
several candidates i mean there's a poll
conservative phone poll of tory members
today which put penny mordent at the top
um closely followed by kami badanok who
of course doesn't have as much
experience but has kind of captured the
imagination of many on the tory right um
there's obviously liz truss who is was
previously the favorite amongst the tory
membership and still might uh end up on
the final ballot at the last two if she
can persuade enough of those uh into the
erg the pro brexit grouping to back her
some of them are a bit cautious because
of course she was a remainder she was a
long time ago a liberal democrat and
they might prefer the uh the more
authentic um
uh approached or beliefs if you like
like that um of someone like sewella
braverman who has uh
is currently sort of you know the erg
candidate so there's a battle going on
there as well and it has you know
started to get a bit nasty really but as
harry rightly says
the tory party
has this long contest ahead yes the
early stages are going to be over by
next week but then of course we have two
months pretty much of the two leading
contenders going around the country and
they need to be really careful that they
don't end up um
looking more like they're more
interested in fighting than they are and
running the country and we all know we
see a lot of labour's experience
historically and we've seen that with
other with other parties as well the
public don't have any patience
particularly when they're in the middle
of a cost of living crisis um for
example they regard the self-indulgence
of politicians fighting amongst
themselves rather than putting the
interests of the lecturer at first yeah
and looking at this sort of conservative
obsession with tax when
people have got a lot more to worry
about on their plate at the moment let's
bring in the daily telegraph harry
potter sanji javid um sweating away at
his uh news conference today as javid
swelter's sunax says he will cool it on
taxes is the headline there um what's
quite interesting is that uh there was a
poll of conservative home um readers uh
several thousand tory party activists
today which showed that penny mordent is
uh are at number one in terms of who
people want is leader and sajid javid
actually quite far down the pack
yeah there's um
uh there's a real suggestion tonight
that while he might get the 20 votes
requisite to get onto the ballot on
wednesday um it's not necessarily
guaranteed that he's got the thirty
yeah to to stay in um on wednesday's
first round a fairly brutal elimination
round there um now let's uh subscribe it
is a you know i felt quite sorry for
today actually launching on the hottest
day
of the year and i think it was sky news
that had the sort of temperature gauge
in the in the top left-hand screen of
sort of 31 degrees
at
heathrow airport just as he was standing
up in a very small crowded room in
westminster to get to give to give that
speech but he got through it in the end
um i think he liked the bit where he
called for a clean campaign and everyone
to stop uh you know having to go each
other and then proceeded to tear chunks
out of a number of his rivals but that's
what we can come to expect for the next
few days um but really i think we should
know by the end of this week
who's really in it and i think the the
expectation being that it will be rishi
and a.n other in the final in the final
two and there's a big push by liz trust
to sort of unite the rights as pippa was
saying whether it would be her or
another candidate i think she had can
play on that that cabinet experience
that she has the fact that she has dealt
with chrysler she's had she's been at
the forefront of the uk's response in
ukraine and frankly junior ministers you
know suella braverman yes she was in the
cabinet but she was a law officer uh and
kevin badenock a junior minister for
paper clip somewhere leveling up i think
it was yeah you know you could make a
pretty good case that when the red phone
is ringing at three in the morning as
the famous famous us tv ad goes who do
you want answering it do you want
someone who's never been tested before
or frank or someone who's been at one of
the top four jobs in the cabinet yeah we
hear a lot about that in the coming days
yeah um but just a very quick thought
we've got to go to a break but just
wanted to get your thoughts on the front
of the mail um trust back me or it'll be
rishi echoing your comments earlier
yes that's absolutely her strategy um
she wants to be the other candidate
going through to the final round to the
members because she thinks i think
probably rightly that faced with the
choice of a candidate to the right and
russia sonak the membership may well
back her
okay uh great we will speak again in a
moment coming up after the break we're
going to be talking about why yet more
hot weather could lead to a national
emergency disturbance
[Music]
hello again we're going to talk about
the heatwave now with pippa and harry
front page of the daily telegraph pipa
it might reach 40 celsius this weekend
we could see the first ever national
heatwave emergency declared what would
that mean
well it would be pretty dramatic i mean
we're sitting here already aren't we all
sort of feeling rather
lethargic probably at this point
in the evening
but we could see it potentially rise
another 10 degrees we sort of i've got a
sister who lives in perth in western
australia and periodically she tells me
that it's 40 degrees there and you know
i take it aback by how they managed to
cope with it but of course they've all
got aircon and they're equipped for it
we're not in this country
and there was a telegraph reports that
there was a cobra meeting an emergency
meeting inside government today to talk
about this emergency
um which could have an impact on
everything from roads and rail i don't
know whether you saw the really quite
striking images today of a track in
london bursting almost spontaneously
into flames a rail track because it was
overheated and one of the electrical
points had exploded
as as a result of as a result of that
heat um we might see schools having to
close because of course schools in this
country aren't equipped to deal with
extreme temperatures um very few of them
if any have air conditioning mostly it's
a case of having to kind of like wrestle
the rusty windows open to try and give
the kids a bit of they've all been open
because they've covered haven't they
they're getting quite used to that now
no
maybe so but uh it's certainly not the
same as aircon is it um and there's even
suggestions that it could be it could
obviously create pressure huge extra
pressure on uh health and social care
not just of course because um
because the you know whether they'll be
able to manage logistically but also
because of course uh elderly people will
be particularly vulnerable and many of
them uh are the occupants of care homes
so
that they're the people looking after
them have to do a great deal to try and
keep them cool and and hydrated so you
know there's obviously a lot of concern
it's not something we're used to we see
this in britain when we have extreme
weather we also see in the winter when
we have extreme weather we're just not
really very well equipped for it because
we're not used to it um so i think a bit
of careful planning and maybe not trying
to try to take life a little bit slower
yeah that would be good harry one very
quick thought on this
this is again a story our class has
coveted broke britain the first instinct
now is everything is an emergency
everything needs a cobra meeting
everyone has to stay at home it's too
sunny it's too wet it's too cold a
little bit of snow the whole country
just breaks down and everyone wants to
stay at home i just think we need to
snap out of this is it
yeah
reach for a glass of ice water